I don't know if you've heard of that
little game called Pokemon go but it
sounds like people are playing the new
augmented reality game in places they
probably shouldn't Pokemon go encourages
players to get out and explore the areas
around them in order to catch pokemon
but if you were thinking about playing
the game in or around the holocaust
museum you probably shouldn't it's been
revealed that the Holocaust Museum in
Washington DC is a polka stop in the
game in the museum is not too pleased a
communications director from the site
told Washington Post playing the game is
not appropriate in the museum which is a
memorial to the victims of Nazism the
director said the museum is currently
trying to determine if the Holocaust
Museum can be excluded from Pokemon go
we have reached out to developer niantic
labs to see what might be happening here
right now players can report issues with
a Pokemon gym or polka stop but only if
they present immediate physical danger
according to niantic examples provided
by niantic include middle of the road or
railroad tracks the Holocaust museums
list of rules does not include any
mention of playing video games while at
the site the museum does mention that
attendees should be respectful of the
site and other visitors during their
trip have fun playing pokemon go but
remember to be safe and realize that
there are some places where maybe you
shouldn't try to catch them all for more
on Pokemon go stay tuned to gamespot
you